hi there Steve here i'm going to start
up my audio recording setup steve
kaufman here and what I'm going to do
for the next little while is that I'm
going to record my videos and I'm also
going to report them as podcasts and I'm
going to provide transcripts and this
will make it possible for people who
want to use these for language learning
to do so and I'm going to talk about two
types of subjects I'm going to either
talk about language learning or I'm
going to talk about other column
intresting topical controversial
subjects which I hope will be
interesting for people to listen to
because in language learning if the
subject is interesting you're more
likely to learn and certainly that has
been my experience with my Russian
studies ever since I discovered echamos
fee I have just been fascinated by the
range of interviews and even commentary
daily commentary monologues that the
various journalists on FM esprit have
had provided with have provided me with
now I am NOT a mini multitasking
chemistry but I'm going to try to
somehow do what they do and I'm going to
provide video as well even though I
personally don't believe that video is
all that helpful in language learning
but I asked the question here at my blog
at the linguist on language and I would
say a majority of people who answered
said they liked video now video is in a
movie with action and people talking to
each other is a lot more fun than
looking at some old coot deliver a
monologue but since I can't provide a
drama here all I can provide is me
talking in a video and I will also
provide the the audio as a separate file
and the transcripts now um what am I
going to talk about let's talk about a
few things here first of all I want to
stay on the subject of political
correctness because it does relate to
how we use language and I make the point
that
I think we should be free to express
ourselves freely without being
constrained by sort of new techniques of
dialogue in making sure we're nice to
people because all of that is hypocrisy
and whenever I have come across people
who who tell and tried to tell me how I
should be more considerate and and not
try to impose my views and this they are
the most intolerant of anybody's views
that don't conform to their so I will
consider that to be just an attempt to
squash other people's points of view now
I want to talk a bit about something
that came up on FM us v which is this
very fascinating radio station in Russia
that is available online and where you
can download both sound files and text
files which I import of course into
int'l inc and it seems that in Russia
minister and apparently a very highly
respected minister of the government
there has proposed a piece of
legislation that would make it a crime a
criminal offence in Russia to deny that
the Soviet Union one what is known in
Russia as the Great Patriotic War they
don't refer refer to it as the Second
World War is known as the Great
Patriotic War and of course it is true
that the Soviet Union suffered by far
suffered greater casualties than any
other of the Allies it is also true that
the Soviet Union probably was
instrumental if not decisive in
defeating Hitler because Hitler
committed more troops into the Soviet
Union than anywhere else there were some
absolutely monumental battles like
Stalingrad and combinate the combination
of the Soviet manpower industrial
capability that was set up back of the
front in the Urals whether to some
extent but mostly this absolutely
incredible mobilization of the human and
and industrial resources of the Soviet
Union it was responsible
the defeat of Hitler now why would you
have a law that made it criminally a
criminal offense to deny that the Soviet
Union won the war are other people out
there saying that the Soviet Union lost
the war I haven't heard them and many of
the commentators unanimously were of the
same tone that this was rather
unnecessary and I think a vote amongst
their listeners found 75% who said that
this was not necessary however it raises
some interesting points as again the
commentator and echamos Lee made the
point well he said what if you for
example there's a very famous film that
were things there was a film a
documentary that was produced in Russia
which said that the Russian army was
poorly prepared poorly LED in certain of
their bottles and this contributed to
massive losses which were unnecessary in
other words they criticized some of the
actors some of the officers are some of
the people who were involved in the
Russian defensive of the motherland now
a leader of the Veterans Association in
the soap in Russia has said that the
person who created this documentary not
only should be put in prison but he
should be hanged he's a good old I find
that tone in Russia is very common you
know they don't come out two and half
measures it's hanging um because of
course he has offended the memory of
many people who died defending Russia
against Hitler resumen eventually
defeating Hitler so should we be allowed
to say things that might offend people
you know what if it's true that there
were officers who were incompetent or
drunk or committed troops to battle
before they were ready and caused
unnecessary loss of life and so for the
zone should we not be allowed to say
that it's similar to the discussion
we've had in Canada about the massive
bombing of civilian targets in Germany
during the war by the Royal Air Force
the British royal
for us and twenty-five percent of those
Airmen that flew over Germany and and
obviously they risked their lives and
they were considered heroes and it was
these were dangerous missions but what
they did was that they just totally
massacred civilians in a number of
cities Dresden is always raised as the
sort of German Hiroshima but in fact the
numbers in Dresden have been grossly
exaggerated for a variety of reasons and
what happened at Dresden is no different
from what happened in Hamburg and a
number of other cities are we not
allowed to question the tactics and
strategies that were used at that time
in warfare maybe we are maybe we aren't
I don't know personally I would be in
favor of a freedom of speech and that we
should be able to question some of those
decisions and similarly here freedom of
speech you know I've been discussing
this we now have this political correct
movement in North America yeah that
reminds me there is a Canadian 75 year
old man of Aboriginal origin from
Saskatchewan who served in the Canadian
Army and who was given the order of
Canada and is highly regarded in the
Native community and who has on several
occasions and in one occasion he gave a
speech where he said the Jews
responsible for the war Hitler had the
you know the right idea in frying six
million of the many said the most
ghastly things he was initially accused
of spreading hate and then it just
recently a judge acquitted him of these
crimes now on the one hand I think it's
perfectly harmless for someone I gets to
say what he said and if not such a big
fuss had been made about it nobody would
have paid much attention they would have
just said he's a foolish old man now
they turned it into a major you know
incident so that his words have been
written all over our youth papers but
now the judge acquits him and says he's
acquitted because he didn't really mean
these comments to be public so I mean of
course that's a totally ridiculous
because he said these
at a public meeting and he repeated them
on several occasions so he meant it
there's no question he's just a stupid
old man don't pretend that but of course
the only reason he's acquitted is
because he's native because that's a
protected group if his name had been
John McDonald member of you know sort of
high-class angle was pink was this
waspish society he would have been you
know castigating that there would have
been hand-wringing and we have to fight
racism this is very bad its widespread
we got to do something so it all depends
on who you are and I didn't you know
we're going to run out of time on this
first video but I also wanted to comment
a little bit on this fellow David who's
come at me on this whole political
correctness front but I'll have to do
that in another video bye for now